we are indeed with Alice Lee Alice a
tremendous victory for you to start off
your first USS Championship with the
black pieces against the third highest
rated player in the event how does that
feel well I haven't really registered it
yet because like this game was like
really chaotic I wasn't even sure about
the readout near the very end but
obviously this is a great result for me
to begin the tournament with and I
definitely wasn't expecting this because
you know she is like very strong and I'm
black and you are under tremendous
pressure early on she played this idea
wrote the G1 G4 G5 she was really coming
at you pushing the pawns and trying to
destroy your Castle how did you
strategize your defense at this point
yeah I mean I wasn't really sure about
the opening because I think a move when
she usually plays like E4 or more
recently Knight of three
um she started off so she started with
three four so I was sort of surprised
for move one and then usually in these
like C4 C6 sort of structures I think I
um usually she plays like D4 and
transposes into a maroon but after Rook
G1 I didn't really know what to do so I
just sort of played safe but it was a
bit passive with like a rookie eight a
knight of Fate Knight D7
uh and I think my play was a little bit
too slow but uh here it's not too bad
um I think I want to do like Bishop B7
and then uh possibly like E5 that was my
plan
um but then she started going down an
attack so she played this move uh G6
after Bishop to D3 this was the moment
did you see this move Bishop takes H7
did you consider it
um
no
wow so Knight takes H7 and now the key
is that she has to open up this diagonal
as well so she needs to sacrifice
another piece it actually makes sense
because then she wants to play G6 and
then the bishop and B2 and their country
one are very strong exactly yes and it
does seem like this one might be winning
for her but she did not spot that uh she
played the move G6 did she play this
move fast uh I don't exactly remember uh
I don't think she spent that much time
on it uh oh she spent eight minutes uh
actually difference here yeah I thought
that like this was good because after F
takes G6 if she does H takes G6 I should
be able to do H6 and close the position
um I thought this should be fine for me
since like I don't see how she can
really attack me it doesn't seem like
there's a way to break and if she does
open up the B2 Bishop you can close it
yeah that was my plan I think uh but she
played Knight G5 which I definitely
wasn't expecting so here uh at first I
saw like H6 should just be good for me
um but then I saw that she had this
Knight F7 idea or also Bishop takes G6
um and if Knight takes G6 Knight F7 I
think and then that would be pretty
annoying that's waiting for her yeah so
um so I was planning to do H takes G5 I
think in the game I did B takes C4 I
took on C4 first yeah yeah how did you
came up to that conclusion that you have
to leave dominate these two parts uh
well later on I wasn't really sure
whether it was good because my Keen was
more open but here I thought that like
maybe at some point I might play some 95
ideas so
um not right now although uh it does
seem that it's okay but I saw H6 I think
H6 were very well calculated and this
was more or less forced at this point so
actually
um after Bishop takes G6 check earlier
uh I was considering a move 18 uh King
G8 but she can take on E8 and then I
thought like maybe I could do 95 but
after Castle's Queen side Queen takes E8
and then F4
um it looks like she has some of those
same bishop and B2 working G1 it's on a
G7 idea seems to be winning for her yeah
no you made the right decision you went
towards the center with King E7 and
actually this seems to have been the
decisive mistake after a queen to A4
already things are starting to look good
for you because your queen is getting
close to Hurricane and this was the big
one yeah Bishop 283 yeah and now it
seems like her Queen is sort of
completely out of play on A5 I mean
especially since my quinoa is on E8 I
think that's better place than on C8
where there might be some I don't know a
night A4 ideas
um so after C5 then now I have like many
ideas like and you found this move d4 to
defend the bishop B7 indirectly yeah
yeah because the Rook takes B7 Queen H1
uh Alice I have to say after this you
play the best moves uh according to the
engines as well just brilliant play by
you defended nicely how does it feel to
win this one and what does that mean for
your chances to potentially become U.S
women's champion
um well of course it's great to be able
to win this one and just get it over
with like black pieces against such a
top seed
um as for winning the championship I
don't really think I can think about
that right now especially since there's
like 12 more games to go and I think
tomorrow will be white against Beacon
and that would be a very tough game take
it one day at a time congratulations
Alice we'll see you tomorrow thank you
our congratulations to you as well Alice